And now, I'd like to introduce today's speaker, Professor Sam Savage.
Dr. Sam Savage is an executive director of probabilitymanagement.org,
a 501C3 non-profit devoted to the communication and calculation of uncertainty.
The organization has received funding from Chevron,
Lockheed Martin, PG&E and others.
And he is joined on the board by Harry Markowitz,
Nobel Laureate in Economics.
Dr. Savage is the author of
The Flaw of Averages: Why We Underestimate Risk in the Face of Uncertainty.
He's an adjunct professor in civil environmental engineering at Stanford University.
He's the inventor of the Stochastic Information Packets also known as SIP,
an auditable data array for conveying uncertainty.
Dr. Savage received his PhD in computational complexity from Yale University.
My name is Pinky Medina,
and I'm the program manager,
of the academic programs team at the Stanford Center for Professional Development,
and I will be moderating today's webinar and the Q&A session.
Now, I'd like to turn the floor over to Sam.
Thanks, Pinky. So,
here's my first question for the audience.
have you had at least one statistics course in your career, yes or no?
Typically if you have,
it doesn't take more than 45 minutes to repair the damage.
Okay, we have a lot of people who have taken statistics.
Let's go on to the next question.
If you have,
one, was it the high point of your week?
you still suffer from PTSD, or other.
Other. Okay. Well, I don't know what other means,
but I'll proceed as if you
have not
necessarily gotten anything out of your statistics course,
and will sort of start from scratch.
So given that we probably have a very wide range of backgrounds,
I wanna sort of level the playing field by starting
with something that everybody understands.
These are the differential equations of motion of a bicycle.
And the point here is that you do not
learn to ride a bicycle through the seat of your intellect,
but through the seat of your pants.
So, my philosophy in teaching and in this webinar,
is to connect the seat of the intellect to the seat of the pants.
And I call that Limbic Analytics.
here's a sensitive rendition from my book
from the cartoonist, Jeff Danziger,
of someone, engaged in limbic analytics.
now, let's start with,
let's dive right in
to a project that has,
we're doing project risk analysis here,
a project that has uncertain durations.
So, here I have a project,
let's say we're building out a website,
and we have 10 pages that need to be completed.
Page one could be product one,
then we have product two,
then we have the shopping cart page,
then we have a legal page.
these 10 pages are being created in parallel by 10 separate teams,
and it's the easiest kind of project to imagine because there's no,
you don't have to finish this one before you do this one.
But out of these 10 teams, and of course,
you're uncertain how long it will take for each team to finish,
but you can't go live until all 10 teams are done.
So, what typically happens now is the boss walks in and says,
"When do we go live?"
And you typically say, "I don't know boss,
because I don't know how long team one will take,
or team two, or team three."
And then the boss will say something like,
"Give me a number," and
I don't know if any of your organizations use that phrase, but
"Give me a number" is the fork and road to hell, because
once you've given a specific number,
you really can't do any reasonable analysis.
Now, let's just remember what we have here.
Each of these times to completion is uncertain,
but everybody agrees that on average,
each one will take six weeks.
Given that,
what's the chance of finishing in six weeks?
So, 100 percent, 50 percent,
taking a while for this poll to fill in.
Okay, we have a winner.
And so, the winner,
oh this is great, I hope we can save these statistics,
the winner is 50 percent. All right.
well, that's not right by the way but it is the winner,
it had almost double what the others did.
Okay. So, let's move on now,
and let me explain
that the actual answer is one in a thousand.
And, it's not just enough to know that it's one in a thousand,
which most of you didn't
but you got to be able to explain it to a 10 year old, or your boss.
so look at it this way.
The only way in which this project finishes in six weeks or
less is if all 10 of these finish in six weeks or less.
And if you imagine each one had a 50/50 chance of being greater or less than six weeks,
then that's like flipping 10 heads in a row on a coin,
which is actually 1,000 in 24,
but hey, I will live with one in 1,000.
Got that? Now actually,
this is pretty serious stuff.
The bulk of people in our little poll said, "Oh yeah,
50/50 chance will be done within six
weeks," when there's a one in 1,000 chance of being done in six weeks.
So that's actually not close enough even for government work.
This is what I call the flaw of averages.
Here's another cartoon from my book.
This is a statistician drowning in a river that's on average three feet deep.
The flaw of averages states that plans based on average assumptions are wrong on average.
And let me say this is based on
a well-known mathematical principle called Jensen's Inequality.
but even most mathematicians haven't heard of that.
So, it is a very important topic,
and it requires some public relations,
for people to understand it.
So, let me give you another more sobering example.
Consider a drunk wandering back and forth in a busy highway,
his average position is the center line.
So, the state of the drunkard at his average position is alive,
but on average, he's dead.
Again not close enough even for government work.
Now, because this is really a public relations campaign on my part,
and that's really,
the non-profit has a lot to do with that as well.
I've come up with an audio logo for the flaw of averages.
So, everyone know what an audio logo is?
this is the audio logo for Intel.
[MUSIC]
I'm sure you all recognize that.
So, here's the audio logo for the flaw of averages.
[MUSIC] Now, let's go,
sort of discuss
how to attack this problem.
There is a cure for the Flaw of Averages,
which is really why the
the nonprofit is around
and it involves two recent breakthroughs.
These are things that most people are not aware of.
The first breakthrough is that
native spreadsheets are now powerful enough to do interactive simulation.
a lot of our
audience here, is familiar with Monte Carlo simulation.
And I'll bet you're not aware that Native Excel can do it without any Macros or Add-ins,
and it can do it incredibly fast.
I'm gonna demonstrate that in just a second.
the other breakthrough
is that there are new standards
that communicate uncertainties as auditable data.
And that has led to the discipline of probability management,
which I'll be describing a little bit further.
It's a simple idea, that is,
uncertainties are modeled as any other kind of data, auditable data.
Now, I wanna point out here that
this is really the most important,
message of the webinar,
that due to these two breakthroughs, anyone,
anywhere with Excel can be curing the Flaw of Averages.
So let me demonstrate this using dice.
Cause we all have a pretty good understanding of how dice work.
The first comment is
that we are gonna represent the uncertainty of these dice as arrays of die rolls.
So, if I look down here, right?
My first roll is a four, a six, and a five.
The second one is a three, a two and a six, and
this goes down 10,000 times,
which is 10,000 die rolls.
I can look at any roll-
by the way, I remember that roll nine had 765 is three ones.
You wouldn't wanna bet against me,
cause it's just auditable data.
I haven't memorized all 10,000 of them,
but that was distinctive.
So, I remembered that. But now is,
is the amazing thing.
In Native Excel, using something called the Data Table.
Data, what if analysis data table,
and I'm sure that at least two or three percent of the audience is
familiar with the Data Table, most people aren't.
But the Data Table lets me roll these dice incredibly fast.
So I'm going to say,
I'm gonna roll the first die 10,000 times,
and we're going to see the percentage of ones twos, threes, fours, fives and six.
Okay. Get your stopwatch.
On your mark, get set, go!
Did you time that? No, of course not.
It was instantaneous, instant simulation in Native Excel.
Here, let's add the results of two dice together.
So, when I do this,
I get the numbers between two and 12.
Two is the smallest, 12 is the biggest.
Do I get all the numbers in between with equal probability?
If anyone thinks so, I hope they brought their wallet.
The answer is, no.
It's not even anymore.
There are many ways to get a seven.
A one to six or six to one or five at two or three, all those.
There's only one way to get a two,
two ones or a 12, two sixes.
This was Native Excel.
It's an XLSX file.
I could immediately send this to a billion of my closest friends.
And look, I can undo it as well.
"Control Z", Minus 10000,
"Control Z", another 10000.
"Control Y", plus 10000.
So, if you're in a Monte Carlo simulation,
you should be excited to learn that Native Excel can do interactive Monte Carlo.
Interactive Monte Carlo means that you can do
Limbic analytics and ride this thing like a bicycle.
So, this is really a miracle.
This is- this has done for simulation what coal fusion,
would have done for energy if it had actually worked. All right.
Now, let's go back to this problem.
I'm gonna show you how you would use this
in a practical setting.
First thing to tell you is,
yes, we have a SIP library now.
So, in the age of Big Data,
a lot of people have data on
how long it takes to do this task and that task,
and so it's relatively easy to set up a SIP library like this.
So that means that when I'm scrolling along here, look at this.
That could happen, or that could happen,
or that could happen.
I'm scrolling through it like a thousand parallel universes.
And notice, when I'm doing Limbic analytics,
you could show this to your boss, right?
Hey boss, this could happen or this could happen, and notice,
we don't go live until the last of these are done and it's uncertain and- holy toledo,
I don't see how ever it would be done in six weeks.
So, I've done this all the time with managers,
and this really catches their attention.
Remember, Limbic analytics ties into the Reptilian Brain.
You know, you see the movement and it's like that scene out of
Jurassic Park with the guys waving the flashlight back and forth.
The Tyrannosaurus sees movement and so does,
your manager. All right.
But let's make this- let's stick in the plot a little bit here.
Suppose there were a contract with performance penalties.
So, okay, someone told them we're done in seven weeks.
And you agreed to a late penalty of 100,000 per week or fraction thereof if you're late.
Uh oh, how is that going to look?
Well, if you plug in all the average assumptions,
you're done in six weeks with no penalty, great!
But I'm not as interested in that as I am in the following.
I wanna know the average of all 1,000 of these things.
See scenario three, scenario four,
we can do this 1,000 times,
I want the average of those numbers over a thousand scenarios.
That's what the Flaw of Averages is about.
It says that the number you get when you plug in the average is not
the same as the average overall scenarios.
So remember, plugging the averages,
you're done in six weeks with no penalty,
but on average, you're done in 7.8 weeks with almost $ 87,000 in penalty.
[MUSIC] Not close enough even for folk music.
Now, let's see how we would manage,
in a situation like this.
First of all, hopefully,
the contract has not been signed yet.
So, you go running back,
and you go to the counter party,
you say, "Oh, please, please,
please, pretty, please, would you give us a $50,000 penalty?"
And they say, "Happy to do it,
as long as you finish in six weeks" Oh, no.
Now, we have a $92,000 penalty on average.
Click at "Control Z" a couple of times. We don't want to do that.
"Well guys, would you let us finish in eight weeks?"
And they say, "Sure,
but now, we are jacking our penalty up to $150,000."
Hey! We're taking that deal.
Look now our penalties are down to $23,000.
Just in Native Excel.
So, I hope you see that there's there there.
We could really be doing this stuff,
and we can be doing it,
we could be doing it now.
So, there is a
template in Native Excel that does a much bigger job of this.
in fact,
if you go to Excel 2016,
there are templates for doing all sorts of special things.
They have several of them do Gantt charts.
So this, what you're looking at here is,
is very much like a little, tiny example,
but in this one, some tasks,
have to precede other tasks,
and it's all done deterministically.
Just basically, these are the numbers and flaw of averages and all that.
I don't listen to a set math model.
Now, we refer to the data containing the uncertainties as a SIP.
So, the die rolls,
look back, those 10,000 trials for each die, that was called a SIP.
Why don't I use SIP.
Well, you already have a little spot in your mind for bit and byte.
So, I knew I needed SIP and Slurp so it would like fit into the same little slot.
SIP stands for Stochastic Information Packet
and, and we will
and we refer to SIP math as running
these SIPs through Excel or any other program as well.
If I click the "SIP math" button,
suddenly, this is looking at 1,000 trials.
So, "SIP Math Off",
"SIP Math On", in this model,
and now, if I scroll through the trials, look out over here.
You see that's where the project and is way down there on the right.
And as I scroll through,
that can happen, or that can happen,
that can happen, or that can happen.
And again, this is just Native Excel.
Another very common sort of risk in projects is,
will the project pay for itself?
Will you make money?
And how big an investment should you make
because you don't know what the market size is, right?
So, demand is always uncertain when you're doing a new product.
So, let's do another example.
Very classic one.
You know, you could argue that these models are just so small,
they're unrealistic.
I say, "Okay.
then, I presume you can solve the small ones in your head."
apparently not.
most people thought that little project was gonna be done,
had a 50/50 chance of being done in,
six weeks, and it's only one in a thousand.
So, here's another one. It's a little counter-intuitive.
We've got a new product or service.
I guess it's just a product and the actual demand is uncertain,
but the average is 100,000.
So, the capacity,
the cost of capacity is $30 a unit,
and the selling price per unit is $40 a unit.
Now, since the average demand is 100,000,
we're gonna plan for a capacity of 100,000.
Good.
Now, the boss walks in and says,
"What's profit gonna be?"
And you say, "I don't know, boss because I don't know what demand is gonna be."
And the boss says, "Give me a number," because he's the boss.
And you say, "Would you settle for an average profit?"
"Well, if that's all you can give me."
So, you say, "Look,
we all agree there's an average demand of 100,000."
"Yes," the boss says we all agree.
So, in a stock,
we're gonna have a capacity of 100,000.
Yeah, that don't make sense.
Okay. We'll expect sales of 100,000.
we're gonna make four million from your 40 bucks a piece.
We're gonna- the cost of, of goods sold,
the fact that we had to tool up and
build these things is
three million, and therefore the profit is one million.
Okay. Well, let's just address this for a second.
What if the demand
was 80,000?
Remember, we're not certain about the demand.
And the first thing I would do would be putting
a value a little below 80 thousand, a little below 100,000,
a little above 100,000, just a first step.
Let's just do these experiments.
Take it down to 80,000 and you didn't make your million dollars, did you?
You only made 200,000.
Sure. But, we know that 100,000 was just the average.
So, it could be greater, it could be like 120,000.
Yeah. See. Well, wait a minute, you're hosed.
You've got a demand of 120,000,
you only have a capacity of 100,000.
There's this nasty little if statement in here that says that,
if the actual demand is greater than the capacity,
you are stuck with the capacity.
Otherwise, you feel the actual demand.
So, if you look down at the bottom,
the bottom line is the profit is still a million.
A million isn't your average profit.
A million is the best, best possible case.
[MUSIC] All right.
So, what do we do about this?
Well,
I like to run a simulation.
Here is a problem with simulations.
I love them. I love them to death.
But, the general public can't use simulation generally because they
don't know how to generate the required distributions of random numbers.
This takes a statistician or something.
This is a serious
block for using simulation.
But, you know one day I realized,
we all use light bulbs
and yet we don't know how to generate the electricity for our light bulbs.
How do we do that?
Well, I figured it out.
We have something called the power grid,
and we run electricity through,
through the power grid and it's generated by experts,
and the rest of us use it.
But, what it required was a standard.
We call it the 60 cycle AC voltage standard,
and the new data standards that I've mentioned
that are maintained by probabilitymanagement.org are the equivalent of the 60-cycle,
120-volt AC current standard.
So, now, let's talk about forecasting,
because forecasting is actually where we get the distribution of uncertainties.
And it generally works like this.
By the way, you can get distributions of uncertainties to feed your simulation.
You can get that from almost any simulation,
or excuse me, from any forecast.
You can get the distribution from almost any forecast.
this one has a 95 percent upper and lower confidence interval.
That leads to a bell-shaped distribution and typically,
so people will do this analysis and they'll create the distribution.
And that's right folks,
they flushed it down the toilet.
That's what they do with it.
They end up with a single number,
and of course, you know what happens next.
[MUSIC] So, let me show you how we deal with this,
in probability management.
You're looking at a SIP library.
It was created using a forecast.
I'm not gonna go into the details of it.
Do you want to hear how the electricity was
generated that's lighting the light bulbs your off?
No, you don't care.
You just want to use the light bulb.
So, think of this as the electricity.
It's gonna contain a thousand possible demands for this new product.
It has metadata.
So, for example, the meta data tells,
"Oh yeah, the average demand is 100,000."
And it tells us where the metadata is stored.
"Oh, look at that, those are my initials." There's a provenance.
In other- this is not just a distribution that the cat dragged in.
and if I take the plus sign,
boom, there are all thousand trials. All right.
So, it's just a library.
Now, I'm going to go back to this model.
And I'm going to open the set math tools.
Now, these are- there's a free version of these out on the website.
And, everything I'm doing here,
I could do by, by hand in Excel,
but the tools make it
a lot easier and they're free.
So, first, I'm gonna do is initialize my model
and I'm gonna say select a library to plug into.
I'm going to go to
an external workbook and webinar and,
there it is, demand.
So, here's the library for demand for my product.
And I put the cursor
in this cell,
go to library input, ask for demand.
Oh, and there's a little distribution there.
Look at that, is that cute?
That's called a sparkline graph in Excel.
And we're now dialed in to
all those thousand possible demands.
So, I can go to demand two.
It was only 75,000,
by the way. Look at that.
I only made $23,000 that time.
demand three, I made my million.
It's auditable. I remember number nine isn't very nice.
nine. [MUSIC] Uh.
[MUSIC]
Okay. Why is it? Let me type in nine.
Let's get down to- let's get up to nine here.
Nine is worth looking at.
Cause on trial nine,
we only had 66,000 in demand and we lost $325 million dollars.
So, remember, you told the boss this is, basically, "Hey,
I expect a million bucks," and the boss is gonna say,
"You didn't tell me about the chance of losing $325 million."
Let's go back and look at the average here.
There is our average and
what we see is that we make a million bucks.
Right. Now, what's happened here is that when I initialized the model,
it created another sheet in back where the data table
is gonna put the simulation and what I'm gonna do
now is put my cursor in the profits cell,
define that as an output,
click over here and a 1,000 trials later,
oh, there's another nice little graph there.
And what this is showing me is that profit isn't bell-shaped at all.
Profit is limited on the upside by a million dollars.
Now, here's the cool part.
There is now a range on this sheet named profit.
That's a column of a 1,000 parallel universes of profit,
and that means I can go up here and I can type,
equals average of profit.
So, the profit of the average is a million.
The average profit has gotta be less, right?
Because it can either go down from a million or be at a million,
but the average is something less than a million or a
million that will be less, but how much less?
Oh my God. Six hundred thousand?
So, the profit of the average is a million,
the average profit is $600,000 [MUSIC].
How do you run a business this way?
Now, at this point
I'm gonna discuss what I
call the Levels of Stochastic Enlightenment.
So, let me be clear here.
Part of Limbic Analytics is to explain everything to,
like, to a 10-year-old.
So, in the Flaw of Averages book,
I've got this concept of red words and green words.
A red word is
some technical thing you heard in
a statistics course and it would just give you PTSD to hear it again.
and in the back,
there's a- back of the book there's a red word,
green word glossary and,
maybe we can zoom in on that, oh.
I don't know if you can see that or not.
Red word, but that's,
the important thing to notice is that red words are written in Dracula font.
That was the publisher's idea. I love it.
so the best way to define a red word is,
something that could not be uttered in a single spur.
now, here I have a red word stochastic and I'm using it to pick, poke fun at it.
But I'm talking about the Levels of Stochastic Enlightenment,
which means, how do you deal with uncertainty?
So, let's start with level zero.
Dumb. The boss comes in and says,
"What's profit gonna be?"
And you say, "I don't know boss,
because I don't know what profit's gonna be."
A good step below dumb, level minus one.
Dumber. Use the average demand and say,
"Oh, boss, we're gonna make a million bucks."
Let me point out that this is also accepted practice.
Worse than that, it's actually GAP,
generally accepted accounting principles, so that's horrible.
step one, smart.
Level one, smart, simulate, right.
simulating, you know,
how many people have heard about garbage in garbage out? Oh, yeah.
It's garbage in garbage out.
You put in a bad distribution,
you get a bad simulation.
Wrong.
When you shake a ladder before you climb on it to paint the side of your house,
you are performing a Monte Carlo Simulation on the ladder,
bombarding it with random forces and monitoring the response of the ladder.
I've got bad news for you.
The distribution of forces when you shake
a ladder is very different than when you climb on it.
So, I wanna know out of all our attendees,
we should have a survey for this but we don't,
how many of you are gonna stop shaking ladders now
that I've told you you've been using the wrong distribution for your whole life?
No. Simulate, it's smart.
Garbage in, insight out.
Let's go to the next step.
Smarter, optimize.
Let's go back to our
problem over here.
So, if you've done the right analysis,
you would know now this is a million dollar project is worth $600,000 on average.
Ain't great.
Can you do something to make the situation better?
So, let me remind you that any demand over 100 percent,
over 100,000, excuse me,
which is the average, right?
Any demand over 100,000 is not gonna be met,
because you only stock the average down here.
So, seems to me we should
increase capacity to above 100,000.
Well, that might be risky,
because you have to spend more money to do that, right?
Yet it's 30 bucks
a pop for that initial- maybe we should make the capacity smaller.
Maybe we should leave it as it is. Oh my gosh.
I don't know what to do. What do you think we should do?
Let's take a poll.
So, our average profit is now $600,000.
To increase that average profit,
should we increase our capacity and spend more money to make bigger capacity?
should we decrease our capacity where we won't spend as much money,
or should we maintain current capacity?
What do people think about this?
Looks like a lot of head scratching going on out there.
Okay.
The increased capacity
wins, got 47 percent,
decreased capacity about 30 percent and stayed the same as 23 percent.
Okay, very good. So, let's go back.
the winners wanted to increase capacity, so let's do that.
Let's just jack this up to say 120,000.
Remember what we're trying to beat down here is 600,000.
Here it goes, 120,000,
our profit dropped- our average profit dropped by more than half, down to 279.
Now, that's reduced capacity to 80,000,
and it goes up, from 600,000 to 600- almost 80,000.
Fantastic. Now, let me make a confession.
This is a problem out of one of my textbooks,
and I designed this problem,
so that be more profitable to increase capacity.
So, I designed the problem and then I simulated it,
and it said no it's less profitable increase capacity and that I say,
"Oh, I must be wrong.
No! I said oh!
I must have built my model wrong,
and I went through that phase of denial for,
you know, 10 or 15 minutes till I found out.
No, I was wrong.
The answer to this question is,
and the next time you see a question like this,
should we make more?
Should we make less? Should we?
The answer is you can't do this in your head,
so don't try. All right.
now, let's go to the next phase with this thing and do
a bunch of simulations for different capacities.
So, what we've done in this case,
is we've run seven simulations,
where we have a 50,000,
60,000, 70, 80, 90, 100, 110,000 capacity.
And it's important to understand what we're graphing.
The blue line is the average profit for those different levels of capacity,
the red line is the 10 percent- the 10th percentile,
which means there's a 10 percent risk that we will fall below that line, right?
So, just for example,
I like to think of this line as risk.
So.
Okay. Eighty is the best.
You can see it in the graph. You make 679,000 on average, yeah.
But there's a 10 percent chance of making $20,000 or less.
Now, one of the things I have to say here about risk.
I don't like to use the word risk.
It takes a lot of caveats before you use that word.
You got to really know what you're talking about.
Here's a question for you.
Is there a risk that IBM stock will go down next week?
Heck no, I've shorted this stuff.
The risk for me is that it goes up.
Risk is in the eye of the beholder.
You must always remember uncertainty,
while uncertainty is just like,
you know, stuff happens, right?
So, is IBM stock price uncertain?
Yes. Is there a risk that it goes up?
For me, yes. Is there a risk it goes down?
For you who own IBM stock, Yes.
So, I'm a little hesitant
to really nail down the word risk, but let's look at this.
We started here at 100,000.
We were stock, we were- we had a capacity of 100,000.
Well that only gave us 60 thousand,
600,000 average profit.
Oh yeah, and a 10 percent chance of losing almost 600,000.
So, stocking 100,000 or having a capacity of 100,000 is nuts.
in fact, why would anyone do anything greater than 80?
Eighty maximizes your profit and gives you less risk than these other ones.
So, I got to draw a straight line here.
Any strategy to the right of that line is nuts.
Now, let's back up.
What if I back down to 70,000?
Well, I lose a little average profit, don't I?
Came down a little bit, to a little over 600,000.
What about Mike, what about the risk of bad outcomes?
Well now, look, my worst pot,
10th percentile outcome and my average are closed up on each other.
There's almost no uncertainty there.
So, there's way less risk.
So, if we have a capacity of 70,000,
we have minimum risk.
So, is 70, is 70,000 nuts?
No, this depends on your risk attitude.
If you want to go for broke and have the highest average profit,
you go to 80.
If you wanna cover your butt and minimize the chance of downside, you go to 70.
But, how about less than 70?
It's nuts because the red line is coming back down and the blue line is coming back down.
So, when you're doing simulation analysis,
there may not be one right answer,
it's going to depend on your risk attitude.
There's a range of answers that are not nuts.
Everything else is just crazy here though.
All right.
Now, let's move on to operational risk, and
we've been doing some exciting work,
with PG&E here in Northern California.
There's an article in the December 2016, OR,
MS Today, and I believe there,
there's links to this at our Probably Management website.
I think we have links other places around.
We'll get you to those links.
It really gives you a nice flavor for how probability management works.
and I wanna give you an example now.
When we say rolling up risk,
one of the great,
great benefits of using SIPs is that we
can roll up the results of independent simulations.
Just think of the two SIPs of the dice.
Like, I could add the first two elements
together and the second two and the third down to the 10,000th element.
I will now have a SIP of the sum of the dice and adding up uncertainties is,
just not that easy to do.
So, here's an example now,
This is not a real live model,
I mean it is it's real and live,
but it does not have a real situation.
It's sort of like a balsa airplane of a model.
we've got 10,000 trials here.
we have a bunch of,
gas pipeline assets,
pipes, valves, fittings.
For each asset, I have three SIPs representing financial risk,
safety risk, reliability risk.
They're stored in the SIP library.
You saw what that looks like.
Now, in Excel, is just pure Excel.
I'll bet a bunch of you have seen these little filter things, right?
Where you can actually say, "Oh,
just show we some of the rows.
by the way, we've rolled up the total financial risk up here,
the total safety risk,
the total reliability risk.
But, let me go to the asset tab, and let me say,
"Hey, let's just look at the pipes."
Click and that was 10,000 trials now of the conditional risk,
given that we're just looking at the pipes.
Now, how do you know if you have a risk model?
You should be able to tell me that chance of something bad happening.
So, for example,
what's the chance that the financial risk is over 40 million?
it's 100 percent, apparently.
Okay. What if I change that to 60 million?
Oh, there's only a 30 percent chance,
that the risk is greater than that,
that the
financial loss would be greater than 60 million.
What about 55 million?
Seventy-eight percent.
So, if you can't do that,
you don't have a risk model.
You've got to be able to tell me the chances of something happening.
Now, another thing discussed in that article and what I'm showing you now,
I don't think anyone in the world has fully implemented yet.
I call it a consolidated risk statement,
because we're still in pretty early innings with probability management making a lot of
strides and,
the technology is changing fast.
But, here's the idea behind a consolidated risk statement.
That- again, got three kinds of risks, financial, safety,
reliability, what I've got,
I'm going to roll it up across a couple divisions.
This really has not been possible in the past to easily
add up the results of different simulations running on different platforms.
Excel, Matlab, R.
you can do sh*t math with 10,000 people with abacuses.
The first person would do the first number, the second person will do,
I mean, it's just a very general open concept.
oh, these divisions?
Yeah, well, that divisions have business units, right?
And then, what goes into these risks here?
Well, of course, the probability distribution is going in,
and so there's the financial risk,
the safety risk, the reliability risk,
and let's drill down a little further.
So, in risk management,
there's an important concept
known as the risk exceedance curve,
and it's really just the flip side of a
probability cumulative curve.
So, let me zoom in on this.
Here we have financial risk.
I'm looking at the blue curve.
And let me run out here to the blue curve,
and it tells me that there is
a 30 percent chance of losing $36.4 million dollars or more.
Right?
And that's right here at the 30 percent level.
now there's a red curve on here as well,
remember, we said risk is in the eye of the beholder.
There's a red curve on here that represents your risk tolerance.
And this means,
if you go down to this end of the curve,
that you can tolerate more risk than you actually have.
That's good. But when I get down here,
and your risk tolerance is below the blue curve,
then that just says you can't live with that, right?
Let's see what this red curve says right here.
Click on that it says there's a 10 percent chance,
we can tolerate a 10 percent chance of losing $38.3 million.
Yet but if I go up here,
we see that there's actually like a 20 percent chance of that, right?
Now here we have some Olympic analytics going on.
I'm going to invoke insurance now against that financial risk,
and watch the curves change.
Oh, the insurance brought the blue curve down below my red curve,
so I'm feeling comfortable.
All right? Now, let's just do a quick time check.
I have one more example I can do,
or we can stop for questions here,
do one more example.
Okay. So
this next one
is an example involving the risk of a project R&D portfolio.
And so
this is based on a real-world example that all the numbers
have been changed in anonymized and we don't have to talk about the actual company.
But I was approached by folks at one point who said,
the way we model
and think of a big R&D pharmaceutical with about 100,
pharmaceutical products, 100 drugs in the pipeline very, very risky.
And first of all,
they had trouble- they could model the finances of any individual drug,
what they couldn't do was roll them up into a portfolio to understand the portfolio risk.
And furthermore, there were a lot of portfolio effects.
This is the kind of thing that SIPs can do very well,
you can use SIPs to roll up risk.
Well, one of the issues was this,
that if you look at the return lifetime revenue of a drug,
that is very uncertain.
The bulk of them make almost nothing.
And there are a few whoppers out here
Viagra and Lipitor, just made tons and tons of money.
The average drug makes about a billion.
And so, what they were saying is,
we've been using this one billion to represent the revenue of a drug,
but gee, maybe we should be simulating that cause there really is a distribution.
And I think, yeah, maybe you should.
so let's take a look at what happened.
They were simulating a whole bunch of different pharmaceuticals,
different drugs, and
they were doing them under a bunch of different
conditions that affected all the drugs at once like the what's the discount rate?
What's the probability of success in different classes of drugs?
And so in particular,
one of the things we were able to look at is well what would happen
if you use the one billion average versus you use the full distribution.
Okay? Let's see if the difference is big enough to view the naked eye.
by the way, imagine now this is all make-believe numbers,
but suppose our NPV target,
Net Present Value target is five billion,
well, right now, it's showing we have a 97 percent chance of us achieving that target.
But that's because we're using a single average over here.
Okay? Now, I'm gonna use the full distribution, and by the way,
this is gonna be 5,000 trials when I click this over 100,
drugs many, many experiments.
It's just like 300 million numbers running through this model.
Okay. I'm gonna click the full distribution and see if you can tell the difference, okay?
Full distribution of drug prices one billion average instead of the full distribution.
So, the average for- okay, can you tell the difference?
Okay, now shut your eyes, your left eye.
Okay. Is that better or is that better?
Oh, and by the way, check over here,
the chance of achieving your five billion target went from 97 percent to 44 percent.
Okay? Ninety-seven percent to 44 percent.
those aren't close enough even for folk music.
All right, so with that, I think I'd like to hear from the audience,
see what questions you have.
Thank you very much, Sam,
for this informative presentation.
I hope all of us can walk away feeling more knowledgeable about your work in this field.
And now, we want to answer your questions.
So, the first question is,
your presentation was incredibly engaging,
can you talk about what the course will be like?
How will it be structured,
and what kinds of assignments will there be?
So,
none of my successes have been planned,
and none of my plans have been successful.
that's why I do stochastic modeling, right?
Life is uncertain.
The class will depend
on the students who take it.
But it will be project-based.
So, one of the first things we're gonna
learn is what I call the arithmetic of uncertainty.
And it will all be done in Excel,
and virtually every week,
you'll have a new Excel,
projects to do.
But what I really want to do is have students go out and search for real-world projects.
I am in negotiations now with some,
with some companies that have project data,
and I'd like to
to have the students try to create SIP libraries.
So that, for example,
suppose I'm pouring concrete somewhere,
and, you know, I know that the temperature is gonna be between
60 and 80 degrees,
and I have to pour 150 yards of concrete,
I'd like to be able to have a distribution of how long that concrete will take to set up.
And I'd like to find
build libraries like this and then be able to assemble them into bigger projects.
Oh, a little bit like that Gantt chart you saw this in,
in Excel, be fun to populate that with real distributions.
Okay.
And the second question is
your presentation did an excellent job clearly communicating statistics.
How would the clear communication,
statistical ideas be incorporated into the class?
Well as I mentioned,
I like to have
explanations that a 10-year-old will understand.
My motto is
this stuff is easy to explain.
The hard part is getting anyone to understand it.
And, at the end of the class,
there are going to be class presentations.
So, we're not gonna have a final.
We're gonna have a class project, right?
And the class project requires you to get up there and not explain it,
you don't get any points for explaining it.
You get points for getting people to understand what you're doing.
And so, I will encourage class participation and
learning how to,
how to explain things clearly
ends up being probably way more important than even getting the analysis right,
or you can't get- I don't think you can
get the analysis right if you can't explain it clearly.
They're just too intimately tied up.
And people don't
spend nearly as much time on the communication aspect.
So, for me, you know,
I think of myself as basically a public relations guy.
this Jensen's Inequality has been
around for over 100 years, and no one knows about it.
So, Jensen's inequality is my anchor tenant and of course,
the flaw of averages is the word I gave it to try to get people to understand it.
And we only have
time for one more question.
This kind of analysis depends on the data you use for simulation.
In your course, will you be covering best practices for collecting data?
I will certainly cover approaches,
for gathering data.
There are a number of them.
The first thing is that people get too hung up on that.
So, remember shaking the ladder
close counts with horseshoes,
hand grenades, and simulation.
And by the way, there are some recent advances that really help us,
turn data into SIP libraries. It's very exciting.
I'm working with some colleagues on that
now and we'll certainly spend plenty of time on that.
but we also have to get you
basically over the hump of doing it with very little data.
Don't get blocked by that.
Oh, I'll just say one last thing about this.
Some people say, "Oh no, no, I couldn't,
I couldn't simulate anything because I don't have enough data," right?
If you don't have enough data,
that means you are very,
very uncertain about what's going on.
So, saying "I couldn't do analysis because I don't have enough data" is like
saying "I couldn't learn how to use
a parachute because the wing of the airplane is on fire."
Thank you very much,
Sam for answering these questions.
We are the top the hour, so unfortunately,
we will not have time for additional questions.
If you'd like to learn more about the course,
please don't hesitate to reach out to us directly.
Our contact information is available on our website scpd.stanford.edu.
Also, make sure to check your inbox for the webinar recording within the next two weeks.
Thank you again for joining us today,
and we wish you all the best as you pursue your education goals.
Thanks for attending.